des bâtiments en ruine des carcasses de
véhicules militaires hors service sur
ces images de la télévision d'État on
aperçoit les troupes russes pénétré dans
la localité de marinka une place forte
de l'armée
ukrainienne le ministre de la Défense
rus Serge choou affirme que la ville a
été complètement
libérée ser tout d'abord je tiens à vous
féliciter c'est un
succès
deuxièmement et ce qui est le plus
important veuillez transmettre mes plus
chaleureuses
félicitations et mes paroles de
gratitude à tout le personnel à tous les
militaires qui ont pris part à
différents moments à différentes étapes
au combat pour la libération de
marinka une prise stratégique pour la
Russie qui espère ainsi éloigner
l'artillerie ukrainienne de la ville
séparatiste de donet côté ukrainien un
porte-parole de l'armée affirme lui
qu'il y toujours des soldats Ukrainiens
dans la ville la localité serait
complètement détruite mais l'armée
ukrainienne affirme que des combats
continuent à marinka des combats qui
restent intens en cette période de Noël
l'Ukraine affirme avoir abattu CIN
avions russes ce lundi notamment à
proximité de rerson